I mean yes oh my god oh my god
sometimes Oh somebody's always saying
that you know oh my god oh my god people
say it so differently you know oh my god
a bomb hey this was grazed Oh am I going
oh my good a lot of different ways to
say that oh my god
some people just it's all one word oh my
you know some people say oh my god
Nebraska you're like now that's not oh
we got the studio's looking retightened
and uh that's uh
producer Nick really I mean it's if you
get a chance to look on the youtubes and
and just really fill your face with the
beautiful background that we got going
on here sweet taste of Americana right
here a lot of sweet things that people
have brought us and gifts that people
have brought us we got the strap right
there TF ATK guest of the year - a lot
of nice things dude I was just in the um
so it's Saturday I got to tell you that
because I have to leave today to go to
this to go out of town I'll talk about
that in a little while but um I'm in the
bathroom here at the office building and
there's a man in there and he is and I
go to the I'm using the sink I do toilet
and sink I do a wall toilet you know for
yell only and I'm and then I go to um
and then I hear somebody in one of the
booths and one of the you know the
Dookie booth and I look over somebody
okay a man I would say it was a man
because the shoe size was probably more
than it looked like at least nine and a
half or more or
somebody is facing the wrong way on the
toilet you know what I'm saying
somebody's just you know when cuz you
know a toilet most I think I thought
everybody sat one way on the toilet and
then I see this fella you know this
little law this little Olympian and he's
in the hair facing the wrong way
okay just hugging tank you know and I'm
just like damn this guy I mean maybe he
has like poop dyslexia or something I
don't even know but this guy you know
when I said a quick prayer form inside
of myself you know drop the kewpie on
him and uh and God I mean just you just
wonder how people end up like that and
this was an adult I mean my brother and
I you know when were children and stuff
like that and when water was scarce
sometimes if we couldn't you know mom
wouldn't want us flushing the toilet
that much and so we would go back to
back on the toilet and try to you know
empty our bodies out you know whoever
could do it faster and then just you
know do one flush but but to see a grown
man and not see him but just to see the
legs of a grown man and know he's just
in there just hugging tank boy I just
you won't see me doing that you won't
see me just just gripping that tank that
booty aquarium brother back of a toilet
you won't see me I sit face forward on a
toilet but both my legs out fun to me
like God intended I'm out here doing the
devil's work that's for sure eleska
[Music]
she's been known to bring a man to his
knees she'll take oh you have you never
see your comment he'll take all you have
baby you never see her come as how I
know the devil has a warm arm
[Music]
will mr. Johnson news cuz it's not her
pulse in the Delta mm-hmm
the man if you don't mind would you tune
this gets off of me him him but you took
it so and she broke his heart just for
fun just for fun I passed out though
[Music]
that's how I know the devil is a woman
and that is a bishop gun right there and
just just shooting that devil as a woman
right in your ears isn't it crazy that
there's holes in your head and think
about all of them okay let's think about
them you got ear holes they collect
sound so what else collect sound sponges
hallways I guess or like a cave then you
got your nose you can smell it that
crazy that you could smell stuff you
could in you can bring air into your
face and then and then you know that if
the air smells like something or doesn't
that's crazy isn't it
think about that a peach cobbler you
know yeah it could be anything
oh man somebody somebody didn't burn a
rubber out here while I was sleeping
somebody's been squealing the tires I
look that's crazy that you can just make
air come into your face and then guess
and then unique and you know what's what
kind of smell is out there and that just
to me that's something we should talk
about more what's going on welcome to
this past weekend it is Saturday today
and uh and what was that thing in about
oh I'm thinking about this man I'm
thinking about my body today and then we
have the mouth and the mouth can do a
lot of different stuff it's a real it's
really the airport of your head the
other you know the nose the eyes do a
good bit a lot of traffic coming in a
lot of color traffic coming in and out
of your eyes you know your eyes are
connected pretty much
your brain your eyes are like little
color brains that are kind of just
loitering outside of the lobby of your
brain like they're outside doing a
cigarette while your brains and you know
still on the clock but your mouth is
really like the airport you know they
got there's a lot of there's not there's
like a lot of you know you got air
coming in words going out tastes you got
food you know you could be doing a
sentence or you could be doing a taco
you know your mouth has a lot of a lot
of in and out a lot of you know
importing and out porting through your
mouth
so really unique that are that your head
has all of that going on that amazing I
mean your head is like a damn train
station and they got sound trains air
trains color tray you know it's just all
aboard we doing it we doing it what's
going on boy I was thinking um I was
thinking yesterday about that my skin is
starting to look a little bit old that's
what I started thinking man I was like
damn [ __ ] my skin is getting old boy
in that weird when you see something
your body you're like damn this shit's
starting to fall apart like our if you
see like your leg and a picture
something you're like damn um
my leg is [ __ ] up I'm always shocked
when you see like when you have one of
those moments you're like oh wow you
look at a picture yourself from a few
years earlier you're like damn I was
young I was fine as [ __ ] but then you
didn't think you were fine back then
remember that I always hate that you'll
see a picture yourself from like seven
years ago or even you know 19 years ago
and you'd be like damn I was attractive
and I didn't and I didn't have it I just
had no confidence I'm like gosh
why didn't I know that I was you know a
handsome enough or or or you know we're
fine enough it's like damn look how nice
I looked I didn't realize that I didn't
have that confidence I hate that man it
boils my damn beef that boils my beef
and makes me upset man but but not as
upset at that as that do with damn
freakin doot-doot in the toilet on the
wrong just hugging that tank but maybe
he's going through something I probably
should have checked on I'll check if if
this if this episode I'll check at the
end and if he's still in there what if
he's death so I don't want to think
about that but if he's deceased huh Here
I am making a podcast laughing about the
guy you know who's trying to you know
who's trying to bat left-handed on a
toilet and in the guys Jesus I hope he's
all right
what's going on uh I got some new tour
dates to announce to you and I know
people were upset because of some of the
ones that happened and and I had to
change stuff for the doing this movie
I'm about to leave right now it's
actually it is Saturday I had to record
this and I'm leaving to go over to
Atlanta because when Chris Pratt said
hey brother I need you to come help me
fight alien as I say okay i'ma come
fight I'm uh I'm gonna do that because
he's already been in the future and help
battle stuff and so he knows what's
going on you know he's already taking
care of some stuff and so he needs help
what else ma'am what else how what's
going on oh just been trying to rest
trying to relax and uh and I got a bunch
of great calls that came in I got some
new tour dates I do want to announce
them
but first I want to I want to say this
Oh
people talking about the Jimmy John's
guy do Twitter hi [ __ ] in hate Twitter
man huh Twitter just gotten so lame
it's uh I just don't understand it I
don't understand why why I don't know I
don't know it's just gotten so lame I
wish somebody would just make a Twitter
just for everybody I wish it's kind of
social media and everything or just for
everyone you know for everyone there's a
lot of fake outrage this is one of the
thing I saw in their fake outrage over a
resurfaced photo of Jimmy John's founder
pictured with a hunted down elephant has
caused some people to call for a boycott
of Jimmy John's look if you don't want
to eat Jimmy John's don't eat it but
I'll tell you this I'm eating it okay as
long as they don't put elephant on the
arm on my turkey Tom baby I'll be out
there I'll be out there by the Jimmy
John's you know that dude I wear two
pairs of Underpants brother when I go to
Jimmy John's because I need something to
keep my dick down you feel me because
their sandwiches make me damn it wrecked
and yeah if you're upset that Jimmy John
killed a [ __ ] lyin bruh then guess
what oh well all right now do I think he
should be allowed to shoot a line with a
gun
no I think if you want to fight an
animal you go fight an animal out there
mano a mano e an e ma no you know what
you know what off the same boy mano an e
mano you fight and you fight an ante
mano but you don't fight him with a gun
you shooting something I've said this
before you shooting something from 200
yards away you and your buddies they're
you know snapping into a slim jim run
looking at each other's ass cheeks and
wanting them little you know cages or
whatever no no Jimmy John you want to
battle something get out there and
battle something
and also yeah I'd love to see you maybe
they should have more exotic meats at
the sandwich shop anybody ever thought
about that because yeah most of the
animals he's killing turkey tuna what do
they have a Jimmy John chicken that [ __ ]
is easy to kill brah
dude I'll kill a chicken with a [ __ ]
piece of yarn bro
sneak up on that [ __ ] boy and get him
Italian style from the back but you're
saying you know I'm glad to see at least
he's challenged more hard-hitting
animals but and look dude if I'm fully
honest I'd have a little bit of fat
break throw a low elephant on him on a
bread boy that had me a couple cuts of
fant Bronson [ __ ] him on a brioche roll
doctor called the doctor yes oh look I'm
uh I'm I don't think I don't think
anybody should kill a big animal like
that with a gun you want to get out
there and fight them face-to-face then
do it you put to boxing gloves on on
Jimmy and you put one boxing glove on
that trunk of the arm of that elephant
and let them do it out you know best of
three or something so but I mean you
can't hate the guy forever I mean you
know these [ __ ] selling sandwiches
dude if you sold billions of sandwiches
and [ __ ] you probably lose your mind too
and do something crazy in Africa but I
don't know I mean it's just they want
any anything if it's a white guy doing
something they're gonna shut him down
so that's Twitter basically for you
that's basically yeah I remember
dude this I think he should have to
fight a regular elephant now that's the
rule then you want to kill one okay
second one you got a you guys got to go
at it I like that I want to announce
these reschedule European tour dates
please note that tickets will go on sale
this Tuesday August 27th at 10 a.m.
local time so people are like what what
time is that here that's 10 a.m.
wherever here is the ticket links for
the original shows will be the same for
the rescheduled dates tickets will
transfer over so if you had a ticket for
the original show you can just transfer
your ticket over to the new date if you
have questions or concerns about
switching over your tickets or any other
questions please contact the venue box
office or the point of purchase and they
will be able to help facilitate ok
they are Saturday January 4th is
Manchester Sunday January 5th is also
Manchester Monday the 6th is Dublin
Ireland Wednesday the 8th will be
Glasgow and that's January this is all
January Friday the 10th will be London
Saturday the 11th will be London two
shows Monday will be Amsterdam January
13th Tuesday January 14th will be Oslo
and Wednesday January 15th will be
Stockholm and so those are the European
dates and again you can get all of those
through Theo van comm slash tour and if
you had a ticket to a previous show that
will just transfer over to the new show
but you should check in with the box
office and see what's going on man my
hair looks like [ __ ] bro that's crazy
man oh that's another thing that's
coming out of your head hair and a
little
dude think of all the stuff your head is
doing think of it your head is doing
almost so much stuff to your bodies kind
of I mean it's doing a lot but it's it's
definitely kind of backseat driver a
little bit I feel like but let's take
some calls speaking about European tour
dates let's take a call that came in
right here onward hey Theo its humanity
Oliva what's over here in Germany what's
up Tito onward brother in Germany huh
danke and I just wanted to call him in a
you know kind of give you some support
on a decision to take that movie with
Chris Pratt I have pretty rough year
this last year job losses and changes
lost a dear friend of mine for example
and your show helped me tremendously
that perspective kind of got me through
that and if you month ago when the show
an afternoon coasted I didn't know if I
was even going to be over here
to go but I decided to go ahead and over
the dice buy that ticket and turns out I
found this job actually right down the
road for the show is going to be a so
it's really excited about that I got the
job
Oh Congrats man so you got a new job and
then it's right down the road from the
from that Amsterdam hitter but then I
changed the date it turns out last week
I find out they're gonna send me out of
town for training during that time frame
of show so I watch the podcast on Monday
it turns out you have to postpone the
shells means I'm gonna be able to make
the postponed show after my adoption so
all things considered it worked out well
for me and it's working out well for you
I just wanted to kind of come in give
them some positive news hunters well
there you go guys
one person excited about the change ran
so look if you want to blame it on
somebody we rescheduled them all for
that guy right there
now Congrats on the job man you got that
new job and you're gonna be able to do
different activities at work they're
gonna pay you you're gonna perform
that's beautiful bro that's beautiful
and thanks for the well-wishes about the
film
I mean I'll say film movie I don't
[ __ ] know bro I mean I don't know
exactly how to how to discuss this thing
you know without sounding like a
straight d-bag honest
but here we go
he was going on big dog just cars over
there Charlotte cool
what's up Kaiser over there in Charlotte
gang brah homeward come up along because
you own that we baby
but on that all and that hitter but uh
[Music]
congratulations on the news about the
about the role she died Chris Pratt
Smyrna top since Eisenhower right now
that's so that's an Avenger thanks man
yeah he I mean yeah it's crazy look if
Rosie O'Donnell hits me up to do
something suck at it RORO you know what
I'm saying if who else wanted he's
[ __ ] Muppets I mean it could literally
99% of people asked me if I want to be a
part of something no but I mean this
thing just sliced through the water like
a [ __ ] shrimp with a sword baby and
uh and I was like man this man's asking
me point-blank to be a part of his
project and I didn't know what else to
do except you know he said look I need
somebody to help me fight aliens and the
future needs you and I was like well
damn bro are you sure and and that was
how it kind of started and so now I'm
gonna go you know I guess I'm gonna help
out for the future as much as I can so
all work and um I was kind of thing
cause like what role you were gonna play
I could see you being a mechanic oh yeah
did I like mechanics thanks I'm with
some oil couple of spots on your shirt
you know on your hands um I could see
you probably being a veterinarian
oh yeah boy with that heavy petting zoo
bruh now veterinarian I'm not cutting
into something for no reason
you know I mean I'm not cutting into
something for no reason dude if some of
you know if an animal swallows a marble
or swallows its house keys or something
I'll get in there but for some
miscellaneous you know they got
arrhythmia here and in [ __ ] Judy's
rabbit that's Judy's problem bro I'll
send that thing over to Jimmy John and
let him pop it off you feel me
onward and taking care of dogs and other
animals but anxious and yet he's um also
I want to ask you or Jesus brother will
ask me because this guy might be just
really too high man all word are you
gonna be filming during the diamonds
fight does this mean that you cannot go
to Abu Dhabi that exactly that is what
it means man it is what it means and uh
and that's a bummer too man I was
probably I mean it's just it's been a
lot man out to be honest dude it's like
the past couple months have just been
have been tough well for here first
first my brains all over the place yes I
can't go to the fight so I'm bummed out
about that and what role am i playing in
this show they just need the guy said
they need help in in the future and they
you know that it's about like they have
aliens and that they need help and so
you know I don't think I'm gonna be I
don't think they have a lot of
veterinarians in the future because they
don't you don't see that you know you
don't seem like a guy show up in a time
machine and he's got a couple animals
with him or something or like a um
stethoscope with like deer blood on it
or something
so I think it's gonna be a little bit
more uh you know just kind of like a
normal guy who goes to the future and
just tries his best basically they said
we want you that's what they said I said
well what is they said we want you we
want you too
help us in the future because we got
problems and they're talking about
aliens and also look a black friend of
mine told me that black people and
aliens have beef with each other so I
mean and I told y'all about that a while
back but there's just obviously in the
future there's a lot of kind of [ __ ]
happening that people are concerned
about but what else man let's take
another call that came in here sorry I'm
all over the place a little bit man I'm
just my Energy's all jacked up because I
have to fly out tonight so I'm a little
bit um you know just erratic I guess and
I'm nervous you know I don't know what
this experience is going to be like I
don't know what it's going to be like I
mean they're gonna have people that are
professional you know I'm gonna have to
be in a different type of environment
the things I am excited about you know
I'm have to but I don't know they made
it seem like it's like I'm gonna be able
to be myself and so that was something
that was extremely appealing to me and
Chris Pratt is basically like you know
Jesus's little bucko so it's like you
know if the Lord calls dude you don't
just sit by the phone and finish off a
thing of planners peanuts you know I'm
saying you don't [ __ ] just polish off
some Nutter butters and listen to that
[ __ ] ring if the Lord calls Yello
let's take another call here and this is
the number is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and I'll wait
another question that came in here
through patreon through Danny crook and
it's more about the film the ghost draft
that's the name of it what expectations
do you have as you approach the new
movie project what expectations for
background and context I recently
realized how much on my own anxiety and
depression stems from not managing my
own expectations better
so what expectations do you have for the
film you know it's a good that's a good
that's a good question man I think well
I think um you know I realize this isn't
a film on the star of or anything like
that that I'm not even you know I'm
gonna be a part of it that's all I know
you know it was kind of risky to me to
just to accept that but I have to go in
and I think it's going to be a nice
change of pace in the sense that it will
give me a chance to have a new
experience with something you know and
just have a little bit of a change of
pace you know we all need that in our
lives
you know variety is the spice of life
they say it
it's that cinnamon bra that cardomom you
know I'm expecting that there will be a
lot of downtime which i think would be
good for me to get a chance to rest you
know I've been trying to take some time
off and really just rest my brain my
brain feels really tired and so I've
been just trying to rest it and relax it
and and so I think I'll have that
expectations I probably won't be able to
be you know I'm not going to be the
center of attention and so I think that
this could be just a nice lesson in in
humility you know to be supporting
support somebody else what expectations
I'm gonna try to create some good
patterns for myself on a day to day
basis so that I don't just fall into bad
habits so I'm gonna really work hard to
do that
it's funny man it's crazy how much
expectations I'll have expectations run
crazy in my head forever you know
thinking something's gonna be like this
or like this or like this and I'm not
even you know I can't even really be
present in my own life until whatever
that thing happens is and then if it and
it things rarely can live up to your
expectations because our imagination can
be so you know like I'll sit like if you
see like a pretty girl walk towards you
or a pretty man if you like a man's body
or man you like a man's brain and body
you see them walk at you and you think
man they're gonna look at me they're
gonna buy me a flower or something or a
hat or something we'll split a little
bag of something you know cut a nerd
rope in half and share it but the truth
is they don't they just walk by and now
you're like [ __ ] now I'm all depressed
because that person thinks I'm nasty but
they never thought about me at all and
Here I am you know not taking care of
myself laying on the couch watching two
seasons of Forensic Files and the
homeboy just out there just doing just
mostly death viewing on on investigative
discovery that's Bad News Bears so I
think I'm trying to keep my expectations
low and I'm trying to see if there's
lessons for me in this is the lamest
that sounds a little bit that's what I'm
trying to do so those are some of my
thoughts going into it Danny
crook Gillian Neil had this question how
do you wind down after a show
you put so much energy and joy in your
stand-up I'm just curious how you relax
you know it takes me a while I realized
you know and it takes me usually I'll
drink coffee in between shows and to get
jacked out for the second one so I got
that [ __ ] you know I'm saying I got
that I got that baby brown vinegar boy
that cafe just trying to skeet right out
of my veins and that gets me jacked out
for the second hit
so afterwards how do I wind down well I
used to do masturbation but I'm trying
not to do that so I usually get a little
sandwich I eat a bunch of turkey as like
a sedative I mean I'll do a pound of
Turkey to try and get to sleep because
turkey brah that's just valium with
wings dude if you have enough Turkey boy
gets lights out son
Turkey has ter um what is it having a
tetra fat tetra fan yeah Turkey has
tetra fan so sometimes you'll see
somebody sleep at the Wii or whatever or
the cops pull you over they said damn
man you in and out of the lanes brah
and that's when I break out a bag of
butter boss oh hey look officer [ __ ]
I've had about thirty slices tonight you
hear me so who knows boy I'm [ __ ]
daddy's looped out on that honey roasted
so they don't know they hit you with
that breathalyzer and that [ __ ]
registers farmer John baby you feel me
that breathalyze our baby too gettin
that [ __ ] registers 14 ounces and that
Turkey Tom hit her boy I've had to Jimmy
John's son hold the elephant you feel me
I've had to Jimmy John frickin those
little snack adapt those and hold the
elephant what else what else is going on
man I think I'm just excited you know I
was thinking this weekend about people
have been saying recently like oh man
I'm so proud of you and I was thinking
about like being proud and like and you
know what I was like you know ever
really tough time feeling proud of
myself you know
if I've ever really felt proud of myself
you know
like I don't know exactly what that
feeling is you know I think I've felt
like achievement I felt some sense of
WoW but I wonder if like we have lost
the like I wonder how do we know if
we're feeling proud of ourselves or if
we're just feeling like you know
egotistical or overconfident you know
it's tough to figure out but I think
- yeah just some time I just never could
feel I never I never felt proud of
myself and it could be from a series of
things maybe you know my pant like it
could have been when I was young like I
didn't know like every congratulations
or anything there wasn't you know enough
of that or just could be that the way I
was made that that it you know molecular
level I wasn't gonna be I wasn't that
proud parrot you know I was more of just
like a little you know like a little
while like I just a just the little
canary that couldn't you know or just
like I never I don't know I don't know
what I'm talking about man my brains
leaking let's take another call that has
come in here the hotline as always as
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three if you're a young fella
that's been struggling with something or
a young man or lesbian or woman or
anyone Native American anyone please
call and let us know if something's
troubling you nine eight five six six
five ninety five six six four nine five
zero three here we go here from Leesburg
Georgia again what up dusty I appreciate
you calling in baby
dusty you know what I'm saying son put
some water on the ground you feel me
let's hear it dust um I just had to stop
your latest podcast immediately and give
you a call and tell you this that I I
called the authorities in your area to
come check on you you know just with the
be honest with you man just live you
know what everything is going on with
you just say in on the internet that you
eat pop-tarts with no frosting on us I
mean clearly you're a [ __ ] psychopath
so oh man I appreciate the call uh dude
pop-tarts without frosting that's how
you do it that's that man that's how you
show the ladies you're a man when you're
young you know I'm sayin I ain't sure if
I'm a child I'm not showing up with this
sugary [ __ ] little [ __ ] rectangle
you know he's showing up with this
little sucrose this little glue kajin
shape bruh I show up with that it looks
[ __ ] patented brother looks like
leather almost like a crispy kind of
edible leather I show up with that you
can see the little you know the the
little the base the the cherry or
whatever the strawberry trying to get
out of the little holes as little they
got the little peep holes over there
it's not slop down with this big fake
hard-ass frosting I like that Brown that
little baby and sometimes even I'll take
some peanut butter and put it on the
back of that [ __ ]
but I don't put it on the front cover
the holes where that with uh those
little lava pockets where the little
where that filling is they got that
filling in them and filling is something
that's hiding inside of something mills
you know filling a lot sake it can be
good or bad I mean they'll fill you
they'll fill your pop-tart with
strawberry they'll fill your your teeth
with a metal they put metal in your damn
teeth so who is that the government but
yeah man you could tell the cops to hold
off but I got it I'm holding it down
here oh I'm holding it down here man
with frosting you're an adult
if you eat pop-tarts with frosting and
you're an adult who do you think you are
huh
Stephanie um that lady's name Park I
don't remember Stephanie something well
it's football you know it and it's a new
season Antonio Browns on the Raiders
Le'Veon Bell is on the Jets Odell
Beckham jr. is in Cleveland it's ego
roulette it's ego roulette but the one
thing that hasn't changed is where you
should put your money down on all the
games my bookie is the place to bet on
football every
weekend my bookie has better bonuses and
more prop bets than any other sports
book period this year they're hosting
the first online handicapping super
contest first place is guaranteed to win
at least a hundred thousand and it only
costs $100 to enter hmm now stuff like
that I really enjoyed because you can
kind of play it out over a season you
know I like the thing where you can do
like a a bet and then you can you know
some of them they last longer than just
one game or one moment all you got to do
is pick five NFL games against the
spread every week to climb the
leaderboard and score your share of the
huge cash prize pool my bookie also has
a live in game betting on every NFL game
they got the most rewarding player perks
and I I do like betting on those oh you
could bet maybe is uh you know is one of
these players gonna start crying for no
reason you know if somebody's gonna get
served with uh you know with um parent
with um you know you don't take care of
your children papers right in the middle
of the game it's interesting to see and
I want to say that our listeners get up
to $1,000 first deposit bonus that means
you can double your first deposit just
use promo code PA st to activate the
offer visit my bookie online today
that's my B oh okay ie
and don't forget to use the promo code
pas t when creating your account to
claim the bonus bet when get paid that's
it
my bookie and use the promo code past
when opening your account to claim your
bonus oh man you know sometimes I feel
like episodes are fun and sometimes I
feel like I don't know what they are man
sometimes I feel like I am just [ __ ]
wandering around iPhones I feel like I
got damn lesbians trapped inside of my
body man you know
I mean sometimes I feel like if you just
beat me open with a hatchet or something
they'd had probably damn 60 lesbians
climb out you know so and dude I'll tell
you this they had a girl that had a
crush on me dude this girl kitty when I
was young and man I had a crush on her
too and she was beautiful dude and they
called her kitty because she would lick
her arms a lot and something about it I
mean I was just sexy to me
you know when you see a girl just put
rubbing her own tongue just just damn
down near her elbows for no real reason
I mean yes Jesus brought it's like it's
like almost like going to Florida it's
beautiful
and uh and I remember at recess I was so
nervous
remember that being young at recess
you're so nervous
especially if there was a girl you're
gonna see I'd be like and then every
time you saw each other when you were in
like elementary school or whatever you
just be in a fight like we you never
talk to me and then you'd write them a
letter it says you never talk to me on
it real big and then it'd be like yes or
no and it's like I don't even know
what's going on anymore and then have
halfway through the year they hire an
attorney her family hires an attorney
and they want money and so that's what
I'm saying is going on with a lot of
these matches these days you know you
pass them a love note they pass you back
a affidavit or whatever you know what
that thing whatever they we don't when
they want half your money they want
affidavits money hey we're gonna give
you this right here so we gonna show up
to court and she gets half dude and you
get some of what you previously had and
that's called that affidavit but but
damn Kitty was fine Brian and uh and I
knew she liked milk and I know it's
crazy but that's why they called her
that as a nickname and I knew she liked
milk full
milk not some of that weak-ass [ __ ] do
you see some of that myth that some of
that weak-ass milk bruh this [ __ ] comes
up a little bit soft dude like a brother
from Seattle you know when you see that
week that week milk come homeboy
I want that thick thick you know I want
that thick thick that kind of milked it
just mmm tastes like it's got some real
[ __ ] in it why are you drinking it
that's what I like
let's take another call that came in
here all word HBO this is Skylar from
Myrtle Beach South Carolina
what's up Skylar over there Myrtle Beach
and have a lot of exotic animals over
there in a Myrtle Beach that's the truth
homeward your apprehension about having
too much on your plate man I feel like
I'm in the same boat I'm in a band I'm a
musician I play in a band and solo going
back to school here in a week's time
and one in my first a a meeting tonight
actually first time ever dang man
Congrats baby boy Congrats boys stand on
the stoop son stand I'll stay on the
stoop they got the steps baby good for
you man
that's a lot long word yeah the culture
of alcohol really derailed something I
had going for me I was in school to be a
music teacher kind of just let that dark
art consuming and I also work a a 10th
job that's usually 40 hours a week in
the daytime so that's a lot it's a lot
of work you got going on let's share
more a lot on my plate as far as that's
concerned
looking forward but very nervous about
my first meeting tonight and and I'm
just real nervous about all those things
coming together at the same time and
it's really got me uneasy it just gives
me a lot of comfort whenever you talk
about these feelings and these things
and wondering how I'm going to push
through with my craft when I'm sober and
completed the treatment man I just want
to say you're awesome dude well
thanks man I appreciate it man I didn't
mean to cut you off there I just man I
just don't like sometimes at this
I mean I'm grateful but sometimes it's
hard to hear here I'll listen to the
rest of it I'm getting you the man gang
brah appreciate that no it's another
just you know uh some of this hard to
hear people it's hard to you know like
it's hard eh
sometimes it's
I don't know you know you know let's
talk about what you were talking about
then you know you were yeah it's a lot
on your plate do recently man I hadn't
really been 100% clean with you guys
about you know I've been I had so much
on my plate and uh you know I remember
when I was in Arizona and I had to get
fluids I wasn't feeling good and just
been exhausted when I was in Phoenix and
that was a couple months ago and uh and
I kept thinking like oh I can't like
complain or anything about being
stressed or overworked because everybody
deals with that kind of stuff you know
and I wasn't trying to complain I just I
don't know sometimes it's like we create
this there's a culture sometimes where
if we are working too much then we feel
like we can't say it we can't you know
no matter what's going on it's like we
can't say it and I probably should have
said more often like man I I know I kept
saying I feel stressed and this and that
but I just didn't realize how exhausted
I've been I mean just exhausted it was
just starting to hurt me at like a level
of I mean even a creative level I just
feel you know I just I don't want to
burn myself completely out I want to
just you know I need to spend some time
making sure that I'm okay so that I can
continue to do what I love to do and do
it for everyone at a high level you know
so when I do come to do the show it's
going to be it's going to be great and
it's going to be something that it's a
fair trade for the price of your ticket
or the ticket that you're buying that
I'm giving you I want to give you more
than your value and that's what I want
to do and so yeah for me I had I think I
had too much on my plate and I wasn't
doing enough to take care of myself I
wouldn't put enough good stuff into my
holes you know in my face in my head or
anywhere really and I'm not putting
anything really in my butt or anything
like that but you know what I'm talking
about so dude what if your butt was just
like a purse and it was a little easier
to get into wouldn't it be crazy
wouldn't that be crazy boy you're like
damn
and I got oh shoot I gotta carry this
out and I gotta carry these whistles and
I gotta carry this little bitty you know
this small mattress and huh what am I
gonna do oh gosh you know where am I
gonna what are gonna know I'm gonna
carry my coffee and then just throw
those whistles in your bud
wouldn't that be great and I mean
wouldn't it just be cuz really a
kangaroo head that has just like a big
open but like that pouch is really just
a big open you know kind of a really a
big long kind of big front but you know
behold son you feel me
that front behold that pouch so they
could they could put stuff in there and
we're out here and [ __ ] you know you
could barely get anything really in your
butt so I think if we you know if
something we could ask God for us to
loosen up our butts a little not to do
anything crazy but just to help us kind
of care you know get stuff out to the
car that's all I'm saying
but you know I think the probe the the
benefits of 12-step for 12-step programs
and recovery programs can be
astronomical for people and even just
that you know I was thinking sometimes
I'm too hard on myself and sometimes I
just want to I want I want to know what
I'm capable of and you know and it's you
have to learn the balance you got to
calibrate that but yeah if you have a
lot on your plate man then just eat one
thing at once it's okay sometimes now
that's two things if you put a lot on
your plate but just eat one thing at a
time you know don't leave you know half
of a bite here and half of a bite here
and you but you know half your mouth is
they got this and that and everything
and I say yes to too many things I want
to do too much and that's part of one of
my character defects is my character
wants to do everything so it'll say yes
a lot and then who I my everything I am
as a person I can't keep up but I'm
learning you know I looked up stress and
a lot of things like that and I'm you
know trying to see a you know about
getting more fitness going and things
that are just gonna help me take care of
myself better so just you know be
careful out there man and
and I appreciate the warm words I think
I have a tough time here in compliments
sometimes and so that's you know that's
tough for me when I'm feeling a little
bit better I'll go into that more let's
take this right here for you you know
that this past weekend has brought to
you--by Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career take classes in
social media marketing creative writing
mobile photography even illustration you
know if you if you feel like you can't
learn something if maybe it's only
because you don't want to because these
days we all have access to the same
amount of information nobody's really
smarter than anyone anymore
you know it's just do people want to
access the information and and how are
they accessing it and what are they
doing with it zip recruiter has
everything you need to develop that next
skill whether you're looking to discover
new passions start a side hustle or gain
professional capabilities Skillshare is
there to keep you learning thriving and
reaching new goals you want to learn
graphic design try graphic design basics
core principles for visual design join
the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now that
Skillshare comm slash Theo von I'm going
to be going to Biloxi next weekend that
show is on and again I'm sorry about the
Brea shows I know I keep saying it but
I'm really I'm bummed out but you know I
just I have to be smart enough to take
care of myself
you know one thing I was afraid to tell
people how bad I was really struggling
was you know the way
I was feeling and stuff because when
you're doing well nobody wants to hear
that you're not doing well you know
nobody wants to hear that the guy that's
you know doing great on the outside that
he's feeling trouble on the inside or
that he's burnt out nobody wants to hear
that and so you just keep going and you
keep going and you keep going and and
you know I'm like I've to remember that
I'm uh I'm uh you know I'm gonna perform
I'm an entertainer I'm an artist I like
to you know I like to be creative but uh
and so I don't want to you know it's
just been a whirlwind year and I have to
be careful and I got to manage my
capabilities and what I'm capable of so
you know out of the blue when this film
came up I was like oh this is exciting
this is something that you know this is
you know this an amazing opportunity in
some regard it's also real scary another
regard you know I don't want people
looking at me like some kind of movie
guy you know this is my joy this is what
I love doing and doing stand-up I mean
doing I'm a comedian I mean I've been
doing stopping on the road for 15 years
doing stand-up comedy you know I don't
even know how many weekends a year 30 40
there
I would say 30 not 40 that would be
lying let's take another call here and
I'm not complaining I'm just I don't
know it's
just
you know otters don't have that thing
inside of me that will tell me when it
and when it's okay man you you know
you've done enough right now you you
know you're doing enough there's just
that crazy person inside of me that's
just like you know you know that's just
always kind of saying oh you got to do
more you got to do more you're not doing
enough all right let's take one more
call here here we go hey Theo this is
William Bell human one United States
know what you know uh Billy Bell from
the US Naval thank you very much brother
and we love you guys thanks for being in
the Navy brother gang fish everything to
do me and a bunch of the guys listen to
the podcast on the planet man and
sometimes it felt like that was only
thing that's got us through some hot
nights out there and it go oh definitely
boy that's when you got to find a man
what cool skin bar a woman now the good
thing about the Navy in the Air Force
they got some beautiful babies in there
these days dude
hell if you've been on if you've been
deployed long enough you might even find
a man with just long hair and just
having to look the other way and just
but you know and just you know right
right vagina next to his little bee hole
or something or be wild or something but
but anyway man enough of the gay jokes I
know people always do that about the
Navy and everything but I hope you also
I will say this bruh to the Armed Forces
if we fight somebody next I hope you
guys beat their ass bruh how about that
gang long word but uh appreciate
everything you do and I Love You Man
gang gang gang man and thanks for your
service and thanks for your service man
you know I don't know what the future is
gonna hold but if [ __ ] gets out of hand
let's all meet in Colorado or Texas or
something and [ __ ] hold it down
let's take this one last call here nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three thank you guys for being with us
for being here today
[Music]
yeah just don't feel like myself I don't
feel like myself you know what I'm just
tired of not feeling like myself and so
I'm trying to figure out what is going
on with me a little bit
so yeah just it's just been a lot going
on this past month man but I'm excited
we got this new year updates you know
that's amazing it's gonna be January you
don't think I was so excited by coming
over to another - you know another part
of the world and being being good and
doing that you know man I was so excited
I was going to go to Dubai see my boys
fight cruise out of there stop an
Istanbul for four days and then go to
the tour that was my plan and and so now
I gotta fight aliens I just don't know
if ever in my life will I have the
opportunity to go fight aliens like this
now being friends with Eddie Bravo you
got a chance to fight aliens probably a
couple times in your life but this
should be interesting
you know and we did it our way you know
I did it just by being myself and I
don't have to do with some character or
be somebody else's you know pigeon or
[ __ ] work under some you know we you
know do some [ __ ] character this
character was like oh you can be you and
I said damn and that's gonna be
something fun for everybody and not just
for me oh okay let's take this call here
we go man and thank everybody for the
calls and thank you guys so much for
your support
a lot of nice calls that came in this
week to just being supportive so thank
you so much don't word idea cam was up
cam from Charlotte and that's uh
Charlotte is a woman's name - it's also
a city so you know what I'm saying
sometimes if you see a dude just humping
the air in the middle of town you say
dang what's going on boy say I'm just
getting a little bit of Charlotte you
feel me going good twenty years old
young buck trying to figure out my way
in life 20 years old right there double
decades right here onward brother I got
problem with these sweaty hands
like that I problems with it doesn't
have to worry about it but comes a
problem date oh you got them sweaty
hands huh
you got them leaky mitts baby tell me
more just wondering some advice that
maybe you give a young guy sweaty hands
oh you got that drip shake huh hmm I can
only imagine me you try to shake
somebody's hand you and your daddy
probably can't even handshake because
it's just like uh just like to like two
fists trying to uh just like two fists
trying to hook and they can't it's like
hmm
damn home word thank you if you give me
a little advice on what to do with these
headers thanks man
you got them leaky hitters Romney and
the only thing you can do marry a
plumber you notice the old joke if you
got sweaty hands you marry a plumber but
damn boy you got them sweaty hands
that's trouble hmm yeah that's a tough
one man because I mean you could keep
like I don't know if you ever been in
the gymnasium but they have this little
thing of chalk sometimes I guess people
die there a lot or whatever and they'll
put it on their hands or something or um
you know if they're doing uh you know I
guess I don't know I don't know what
it's for really but people put it on
their hands there and you can do it too
so you can put one of those in the
vehicle or something um what else you
got to hold the hain't hold your hands
out of the window when you drive so you
know you could hold your hands right out
of the car window when you drive like a
little love like a little bee Shawn and
they do that sometimes and hang your
tongue out or something - kind of cool
them back then bad boys off because
those are that's those [ __ ] front
grippers baby them hands you got a pair
of them and I mean yeah I don't know
what else you could do do get some
gloves or something get some cinnamon
put it you know or do something like
seasonal samaa Oregon not Oregon
a little bit of ganger you feel me that
ganger get you some of those gang you
know or crumble up some gang of snaps or
whatever and put them on the front get
you right but yeah you need some type of
a dust to cover it now that there's a
surgery you can get you got to get the
gland saw it out of your hands so I
don't know where you want to do that at
but but I would say I think it's a lot
of girls will think it's cute too
you know just tell them they make you
nervous or something I think now that's
a good way in the beginning say oh yeah
you know ho hey violet you know you're
really making me nervous you know my
hands are really just leaking for you or
get you some special gloves some gloves
that match like your pants like Brendan
Schaub is like a guy that will wear some
[ __ ] weird gloves so do some [ __ ]
like that and do something but I think
if a girl said man your hands are real
wet I would say look well look hey I'll
get wet if you get one you feel me now
that's kind of perverse but that's you
know that's not a real Christian way to
go about it but that's something you
could do and what else
mmm man the truth is somebody's gonna
love your damn wet hands they probably
got a lady out there sitting around with
dry ashy hands you know some lady she
just just leaving just real intense
fingerprints everywhere she goes
and people say damn I mean you probably
can't play solitaire cuz the cards get
all kind of law water logged up you know
they get off you know they swallow a
little but but they got some dry dry
lady out there I mean look at this you
mutt your father made you eat you know
he got them dripping mitts so it's all
we've all got something bro you know I
feel like I've been losing my hair dude
that's scary you know I got a big nose
right on the front of my face dude you
know how much easier would be if my nose
was on the back of my face way easier
but you know we've all got some kind of
thing you know I got those [ __ ]
people don't want to talk about them a
lot those claves I got those up top
hitters baby them high ribs and them
[ __ ] are beautiful but you don't see
those a lot you know so we all have
things about ourselves that we don't
really enjoy so I think if you got some
you know just tell them you've been
doing laundry or something you could do
that but the unique thing about it is
there's somebody else out there that's
got it just like you your father and you
have somebody to talk about it with and
if anything it's a gift man what if you
and your father had nothing in common
you know I'd give anything for to have
something you know to be able to talk to
my father and not only talk to him but
about something we had in common blame
him
you also have somebody to blame these
day you could take your daddy to court
sue em boy the state versus drip-drop
you feel me but I think it's something
you have in common with your father and
he cares about you you know he's damp
with affection for his son he's damp
with sentiment for his boy and that
could be anything coming out of your
hands dude who could you know who knows
man
damn that could be that body skeet but
it could be the Lord trying to just just
really blossom right out of your palms
so there's a lot going on with you man
and I think they're supposed to be you
know you don't want to have a dry
existence so I would put some you know
do maybe there's like a powder that's
real fine people wouldn't notice you
could put in your pockets you could wear
gloves really cool chill gloves or
something
fashions gotten so weird you could
almost do whatever you want he could do
some blue jean gloves or something like
that something that's really kind of
unique or like rocky rocky remember you
wore that and he just had a lisp so he
didn't even he wasn't even if
fashionable he has speech impediment he
[ __ ] you know wore mittens so Jesus
Christ Brian he had a great career
I think there's a lot of possibility for
you man and I love you Brian I hope when
I see you dude you [ __ ] shake me you
shake my hand with one of those wet
[ __ ] baby cuz I'm gonna grip that
thing and I'm gonna pull you me and
daddy and give you that one-handed
[ __ ] that [ __ ] lava lock baby that
love that [ __ ] one-handed [ __ ]
love hustle real fast boy that half a
hug you feel me I'm in and out huh okay
I gotta go to Atlanta man they say they
say look man we got to fly you out here
we got to do all of that so we got a
week of training and and that just means
like going over rehearsals and looking
at things and stuff like that and you
know I think the scariest thing for me
is that I've been doing things you know
podcasting is stand-up it's your own
thing and I have to work with others
here and I'm definitely excited it's
going to be cool but it's just you know
I have to remember that so I got a you
know it's not about me it's about a
project everybody's trying to do you
know I'm hoping to learn and I'm hoping
to have an experience that I could share
with others and I mean you guys so Gang
Gang yeah we'll see you guys next time
and yeah be good to yourselves I am
having a tough time like connecting with
myself so that's been really really
tough for me so I feel like sometimes
you know I don't know what's going on
but everything's gonna be okay
do you know that I believe that and just
got a stay in the pocket you know stay
in the pocket in one moment at a time
and don't get its own future trip and
stay in gratitude you know I mean how we
all have a lot to be grateful for you
know we all do and and we're all
listening right we're right here right
now and thank you guys for being a part
of my life man and be good to yourself
and and I hope you deserve it I'm so
grateful that I have you know I have
something
[Music]
you know when they say you want to come
do this thing I didn't just think oh
yeah years ago I thought oh yeah my
first thought was man what I'm gonna
have to do my podcast you know how am I
gonna do it you know what am I gonna do
and so that and so we you know know some
of the episodes will stop then we'll
stop at all room no Monday episodes but
I'm gonna cut back on some guest
episodes because I need to for my own
well-being and that's as far as I know
right now and that could you know I
don't think that would change but that's
the goal right now you know and so I'm
gonna be good to myself because I know I
deserve it you guys tell me that all the
time when I see you in person so thank
you very much and you do the same for
yourself she's got the vibe that burlock
shot of whiskey she's been known to
bring a man to his knees she'll take all
you have you never see a common that's
how I know
the devil has Obama
[Music]
me
you'll save you walls in anything
Matthew wants you to
[Music]
never thing
and enjoy your first meeting brother
hope you enjoy your first meeting man
I'm about to go 2-1 to myself right now
so
[Music]
that he saw somewhere that bound in
Georgia he says she plays a pretty mean
fiddle it's true who believe oh you got
that feeling of gold she will never have
missed out you want and that's how no
ever has a woman
[Music]
that's how no terrorism
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]